[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: This is
the AIY project kit.
With this simple
cardboard box, it's
easy to get a natural language
recognizer up and running.
And there are
limitless possibilities
for what you can build once
the kit is ready to go.
JAMES MCLURKIN: Can
you sing a song?
SPEAKER 2: (SINGING)
This is my song.
It's not very long.
JAMES MCLURKIN: Well, hi, Erwin.
My name is James, as you said.
I'm a hardware engineer
here at Google.
I did work on the
hardware on the kit.
There's a whole
team of people who
did the software, the
hardware, the interface,
the low-level drivers.
And we're [AUDIO OUT] the
Google machine intelligence
that the kit lets
you tap into, I
hope, in a very
easy and fun way.
They do exactly what
you program them to do,
not what you want them to do.
Exactly the same thing goes
with AI or machine intelligence.
There's no magic.
There's no top
secret way to make
them act like R2-D2 or
Lieutenant Commander Data,
or BB-8.
It depends how old
your references are.
So you will find
things like that.
SPEAKER 1: After a
quick demo and tutorial,
it was the students'
turn to build something.
SPEAKER 3: Well,
personally, I want
to make a little spider
leg device that walks--
JAMES MCLURKIN: OK.
SPEAKER 3: --with extra servos.
SPEAKER 1: The students
took the kits home
and came back five days later
to show us what they built.
SPEAKER 3: What this does
is it adheres to action.
It [INAUDIBLE] cereal,
through cereal.
And it goes right into
that device right there.
Go forward.
JAMES MCLURKIN: Nice.
SPEAKER 3: Stop.
SPEAKER 4: It was pretty
simple servo code just
to ask it to go from neutral
to 90 degrees and then back.
Candy.
SPEAKER 5: Getting your candy.
SPEAKER 6: [LAUGHS]
SPEAKER 7: And then for
this one, since we're
using the servos that
only get 180 degrees,
ideally you'd want to be
able to select all four.
But right now, you
can only select three.
So it can only turn so far.
SPEAKER 6: That's
why we prototype.
Right?
SPEAKER 7: Yep, yep.
Enable toothbrush head rotator.
SPEAKER 8: Enabling
toothbrush head rotator.
SPEAKER 7: Ah, this
came unplugged.
SPEAKER 6: Oh, there it goes.
OK, so white's
obviously facing me.
SPEAKER 7: Yes.
SPEAKER 6: How cool is that?
SPEAKER 1: These are a
couple of the projects that
use servo motors
controlled by the hats that
comes with the AIY.
It was a really nice surprise
that the regular Raspberry Pi
IO libraries just worked
out of the box with it.
It made building the
projects that much easier.
Some of the kids, though,
took a decidedly more software
approach.
Let's take a look at the voice
services that they implemented.
SPEAKER 8: Push the button.
Shop for something.
SPEAKER 6: Shop for New
York Yankees baseball hats.
So what's actually
happening now?
SPEAKER 10: Done.
SPEAKER 6: Whoo, so she
just said done, right?
SPEAKER 9: Yep.
SPEAKER 6: OK.
SPEAKER 9: So what
actually happened
was that when it said done, it
just sends links to my email
after finding it on eBay.
So it'll find results online,
send links in an email to me,
and I'm going to
receive those so then I
can quickly click and buy
something if I wanted to.
SPEAKER 11: OK, so when
you say a command to it,
so in this case, that's
food, it goes to a function.
And then it takes this
picture with the camera
by using the Pi Camera library.
SPEAKER 6: OK.
SPEAKER 11: What food is this?
SPEAKER 12: The
food item is within
the following-- candied apple,
raw tomato, Rainier cherry,
or hardboiled egg.
SPEAKER 6: [LAUGHS] They
can see where it would also
think of a Rainier cherry,
because it's kind of yellow.
SPEAKER 13: Pick a
color, any color.
SPEAKER 6: OK, I'll be blue.
Is that black?
SPEAKER 13: It's black.
SPEAKER 6: OK, I'll be black.
SPEAKER 13: So we start off
with a new game as black.
SPEAKER 14: E5 takes D5.
Your move.
SPEAKER 13: Yep.
I'm gonna do here.
SPEAKER 6: So I'll
move this one.
So what is that?
D7 to D5?
SPEAKER 13: OK, pawn to D5.
SPEAKER 14: E4 takes D5.
Your move.
SPEAKER 6: I like
how sassy it is.
It's like E4 takes D5.
Your move.
SPEAKER 1: This is what
happened when some high school
kids got the AIY kit and hacked
on it for just a few days.
All of them were
inspired to do more,
from expanding their
hardware projects
to using more cloud services.
Many of them had never
even used Python before.
And the open source code
that comes with the AIY
was a great launchpad
for them to learn.
So what will you build?
Learn more at
aiyprojects.withgoogle.com
and do let us know.
[MUSIC PLAYING]